his JZ really in the Illuminati is
Donald Trump is Katy Perry am i everyone
from the BBC to Beyonce has been accused
of being part of the Illuminati a secret
group said to comprised of the world's
most powerful people seeking to
establish a new world order even if you
haven't heard of the Illuminati chances
are you've probably seen one of the
symbols associated with them pentagrams
goats even the all-seeing eye that's
found on US bank notes references have
also cropped up in music videos such as
Rihanna's S&M which featured a fake
newspaper with a headline declaring her
princess of the Illuminati so why do
musicians and artists like to play
around with references to the Illuminati
I think quite simply they're just having
fun
they're just entertained by these
stories like many of us are I'm reminded
of a conspiracy theory from 1966 that
Paul McCartney of the Beatles had died
in a car crash on the way home after
doing some recording and he'd been
replaced by a Canadian DJ who looked a
lot like him and quickly learnt to play
the bass and sing Paul McCartney has
never denied this conspiracy theory he's
always kept quiet about it and I think
McCartney like jay-z Rihanna and others
is just entertained by the story so who
are the Illuminati are they really a
shadowy elite who control the world the
Illuminati
work to the best of our knowledge a
Bavarian secret society formed in the
18th century it opposed superstition
religious influence and state authority
they even created a rulebook which
stated that the order of the day is to
put an end to the massa nations of the
purveyors of injustice to control them
without dominating them the Bavarian
group eventually faded into irrelevance
and has nothing to do with modern
concepts of the Illuminati the
conspiracy theory that we know about
today stems from the Discordian movement
the story goes that discordianism began
in 1965 in the office of a Texas drug
attorney two schoolmates Greg Hill and
Cary Thornley used the office vote
appear to publish copies of the
principia discordia the movements
founding text the book promoted the idea
that chaos is as important as order and
discordianism gathered steamed
throughout the 60s and 70s with Hillen
Thornley actively trying to cause
mischief and spread disinformation their
mission was expanded even further by two
other Americans a writer called Robert
Anton Wilson and his friend Robert che
Wilson was editor at Playboy and the two
of them decided they would write a novel
and they would throw all of the great
conspiracy theories into this novel and
call it illuminatus and in fact they
enjoyed it so much they turned it into a
trilogy they decided that it would be
fun to try and spread a little chaos and
misinformation deliberately about the
Illuminati and they did this by writing
letters to the mainstream press by
writing letters to fanzines which
popular at the time but also through the
letters page of Playboy itself they
would also write in letters from
imaginary readers saying that the
Illuminati weren't real at all or were
kind of setting on the fence it didn't
really matter what did matter is that
all these people seemed to be generating
this conversation about the Illuminati
in the idea was that you as the reader
was supposed to question that
interrogate it ask are they really real
the myth travelled far and wide Wilson
and Shea's the Illuminatus trilogy
attributed some of the mysteries of the
time such as who shot John F Kennedy to
the Illuminati
although the multitude of conspiracy
theories that appear in the trilogy are
imaginary they're blended with enough
truth to make them seem plausible
probably the oddest theory was the
suggestion that Adam Weiss hope the
founder of the Bavarian Illuminati
assassinated George Washington and
assumed his identity as president of the
USA believers of this theory point to
Washington's portrait on the US one
dollar bill which they suggest is
actually the face of wise hope despite
its lack of mainstream sales the trilogy
became a cult favorite it was even made
into a mammoth eight hour stage play in
Liverpool launching the careers of
British actors
nyeeehhh and jim broadbent the seventies
print magazine culture seems distant now
from our globalized hyper-connected
internet but Illuminati rumors are still
rife on websites such as 4chan and
reddit where believers swap their
favorite versions of the conspiracy and
champion evidence to prove it's still in
existence ultimately it's not down to a
shadowy elite whether you choose to
believe in the Illuminati conspiracy
theory or not it's up to you thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon